die neue ausgabe der faz woche ist da
und wir beginnen in dieser woche mit
unserer vierteiligen serie zum klima
eiszeit
[Musik]
wir haben uns in unserer runde überlegt
zu welchem thema wir in diesem jahr noch
eine serie starten können und natürlich
können wir relativ schnell auf das thema
klima weil es gibt kein thema das in
diesem jahr die nachrichtenlage so
konstant beherrscht hat dann kam
natürlich auch relativ schneider einwand
oder klima nicht schon wieder ein ganz
schöner overkill allein wir hatten in
diesem jahr vier titel zu dem thema aber
wie man es auch dreht und wendet es ist
und bleibt jahrhundertaufgabe
deshalb werden wir uns in den folgenden
wochen einige fragen stellen wir werden
uns fragen wie werden wir leben wenn die
erde immer wärmer wird was muss die
politik tun was die unternehmen welche
städtebaulichen herausforderungen kommen
auf uns zu wir erstmal brauchen wir ein
paar fakten und die hat uns unser
kollege joachim müller-jung in unserer
titelgeschichte aufgeschrieben und den
gehen wir jetzt mal besuchen wir haben
für diesen teil in dem es um die klima
fakten geht uns erst mal gefragt was
wissen wir denn eigentlich
über den klimawandel warum können wir
uns heute so sicher sein dass überhaupt
einen klimawandel gibt dann haben wir
festgestellt dass vor 40 jahren fast 40
jahren exxon die großen ölfirmen schon
wussten was auf uns zukommt mit dem
klimawandel die hatten klimaforscher
engagiert und wir haben die kurven das
ist hier eine dieser wunderbaren kurven
von exxon die heute öffentlich hinter
die heute auch verhandelt werden vor
gericht in den usa
also es gibt eine fantastische
informationsgrundlage für den
klimawandel in den letzten 40 jahren hat
sich so wahnsinnig viel getan dass wir
heute sehr viele evidenzen vorliegen
haben und denen wir nachgehen und haben
das ganz konkret aufgeschrieben sie
sehen sie wissen noch längst nicht alles
übers klima also nehmen sie sich ein
paar minuten und lesen sie die wochen